somebody turn the air conditioning on in
here and i want to kiss them on the
mouth and then give them the ratio okay
like where did that vet just
come from and where has it been this
whole time it's right above us there's a
vent and it just started
i think the ac guy is here because zach
was saying he's coming today and he just
go give him a big chance getting
fellatio
when he's done
and then we'll totally understand
go give him a big kiss
on them no
literally a percentage of our the ads
today like we're gonna give him like a
commission on this episode
it feels
like
my mood suddenly shifted i'm like why am
i feeling gloriously delightfully happy
wow oh my god thank you that just gave
me exactly what i needed okay
[Music]